VIKAS MARWAHA: So
as you all know,
Ayushmann is not only a singer,
actor, television personality.
At the age of 20, Ayushmann
won "MTV Roadies 2."
You know how hard
it could be, like,
winning "MTV Roadies
2" at the age of 20,
which is a great accomplishment.
And then we saw him
an ever popular VJ
for MTV and "The
Voice of Youngistaan,"
with which he won the
hearts of millions of youth.
A native of Chandigarh, he has
become a national heartthrob,
bagging critical acclaims
for movies like "Vicky Donor"
and "Dum Laga Ke Haisha."
Welcome to Google.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Hi.
[APPLAUSE]
Frankly speaking, I was not
expecting this gathering.
I thought it was
just a Google chat,
I'll be online
chatting with people.
But this is in real
flesh and blood.
Good to see you guys.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Welcome
to Google, bro.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Thank you very much.
VIKAS MARWAHA: It's
great to see you,
like, your energy is just great.
I love it, man.
That's awesome.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Were
you there last night?
VIKAS MARWAHA: I wasn't there.
But--
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: You have
no idea about my energy then.
AUDIENCE: We are real
friends over here.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: You
were there, of course, yeah.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So this is your
first North American tour.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: How
has your tour been so far?
VIKAS MARWAHA: In
fact, technically,
it is not a first visit to
Frisco this is and Jose.
This is the second
time I'm here.
I was there for the
Independence Day parade in 2013.
But the performance, I think
the energy was amazing.
There is a sizable size of
Indian diaspora staying here.
And it's always good to see
Indians away from India.
I think the connect that
they have with the country is
through music, through cinema,
through cricket, through food.
So I think I'm glad
of those four things.
VIKAS MARWAHA: We have a
lot of questions for you.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
How old are you?
VIKAS MARWAHA: I'm 34.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
You're older than me.
VIKAS MARWAHA: You're probably
three years younger than me.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: You
look younger than 34.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
OK, so Ayushmann, how
did your childhood
go, your family shape
you who you are today?
Like it was your parents
a lot supportive in you
becoming a singer, actor.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I seriously feel
you are combination, or
amalgamation, or maybe
sum total of whatever experience
the experiences you go through
in life, be it your
friends, your family,
I think your peers, your
family, the shape you are,
the person you are
when you grow up.
I had a very middle
class upbringing.
And though my father
was pretty well to do,
but he [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
He never used to give me a bike
or car [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So I think it really helps
you a lot when you grow up
and [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
VIKAS MARWAHA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[LAUGHTER]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And she was like, no,
you can't be an actor.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I don't know.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH] acting,
singing, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Then they are like--
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I used to sing.
I used to act, and my dad used
to say [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
But I think now, I'm sure
she must be proud of me.
She's no more.
I'm a singer because of her.
She used to sing
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And my father plays flute.
But of course they were
not professional singers
and musicians.
But I think the genes
trickled further down.
And I'm blessed, probably.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So tell us,
you went to "MTV Roadies 2"
at a fairly young age, like
around 21, the "MTV Roadies."
How did you manage to let
your fame not affect while you
went to school after that?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I
think when I was 20,
I became really high-headed.
I broke up with my girlfriend.
That was the first time I
was getting female attention
in life, and I was 20.
And before that I
used to wear braces,
glasses, I was very skinny.
But the Roadies were.
And I thought, you
know, I started
getting attention-- I broke up.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Start to think I'm
the biggest star
in country, something like that.
I'm glad I started young.
I can digust fame now.
And I have a stable
head on my shoulders
now because I started
young, probably.
First time I tasted fame
was when I was 19 or 18,
during "Pop Stars." "Roadies"
was the second reality
show for me.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
Yes, that's right.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
But I think it's always
good to start young.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Yeah, how was it.
Yeah, you were facing Raghu.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
He's a nice guy.
He's very sweet.
And you'd be surprised, Raghu
has a great taste in music.
He plays the guitar, and we
jammed together a lot of times.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
So I think that he's
like an elder brother to
me, and he guides me a lot.
And he's a very nice guy.
I think it's just
an image on screen
that people think
that he's very rude.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So--
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
VIKAS MARWAHA:
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
VIKAS MARWAHA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Why don't
you just guys ask questions?
And I think this position
is slightly weird here.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I think we should just stand.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I think I'm standing.
This is much better.
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS MARWAHA: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: When did you decide
to become an actor, or a singer,
or both at the same
time, did you decide?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: Hey hey.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
I think I always
wanted to be an actor.
I think the first film I saw
was [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So I thought, I can be
[INAUDIBLE] without a mustache,
maybe the full beard.
But I think I always wanted
to be an actor, and a singer,
and actor, singer both.
I always idolized
[INAUDIBLE], in fact.
AUDIENCE: Oh, nice.
Nice.
Thank you.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I actually
wanted to ask
you a question from the earlier
days, when you joined MTV.
I recently came across
a [INAUDIBLE] video--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
please go check it out.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: No.
No.
AUDIENCE: It's hilarious.
I just wanted to know
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
because I know, [INAUDIBLE] you
were new there and [INAUDIBLE],
and everyone
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
Frankly speaking, have
you seen that video?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Good for you.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: It's
called MTV [INAUDIBLE].
I think there's two.
Yeah.
Emotionally, I think you are
vulnerable when you're young.
So I think I was just too
vulnerable when I entered
[INAUDIBLE] for the first time.
That was my first job,
in fact, on television.
So yeah.
It happened.
I've grown up.
I was 24 that time.
Yeah.
I'm 31.
I'm 32 this year.
AUDIENCE: I was also
watching, the making of video.
Though you suggested
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And it was very
ahead of its time.
So are there any other
songs that you're composed
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
How were you
introduced to singing?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I think, yeah,
we used to compose
our own songs,
we used to do
theater in college.
Or a college
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I think "Pani Da Rang,"
"Saddi Gali," [INAUDIBLE],
they are all college
compositions.
And "O Heeriye" was recent.
"Dil-e-Naadan" was also
a college composition.
But I think now we are
composing new stuff.
I'll be coming up with
a single very soon.
Next month, we're recording it.
And yeah, I think, I always
wanted to be an actor, and then
a singer.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I
formed two theater groups
in Chandigarh.
And we used to compose our
own songs for own productions.
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Acting career, music career.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I don't
have a question,
but I just want to say amazing
performance last night,
really loved your show.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: That doesn't
sound right, actually, you
know that, right?
AUDIENCE: What?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Nothing.
Just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I just want to
say, I've been a fan of yours
for a long time.
And I loved "Pani da
Rang," and "Saddi Gali."
And I love to sing, but I'm
a fantastic bathroom singer,
and nothing more than that.
But if I were a man I
would love to sing--
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I was
almost a living room singer,
until I was [INAUDIBLE] but
then discovered I should sing,
and I started taking
classical training,
but never took it too seriously.
AUDIENCE: I admire your vocals.
You're a great performer and
a dancer, too, apparently,
but what I admire the most
is really your humility.
You're so down to earth,
and all my friends
that were there
with me last night,
they're like Ayushmann
Khurrana, he's so down to earth.
Anybody can connect with him.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
You know, I just
hope this mask doesn't
drop off of being humble.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: But I hope you
stay like this forever.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Thank you so much.
Wish you were there
for the performance
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Are you working here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah I
do work for Google.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Call your friends?
AUDIENCE: Are you ever planning
to sing full Punjabi songs,
like join the Punjabi industry,
act in Punjabi movies?
You are from Chandigarh.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
You'd be surprised,
my Hindi is better than Punjabi.
Because my mom can't
speak in Punjabi.
I can read and write
in Punjabi because it
is part of the
curriculum in Chandigarh.
But I think in Indian
English more than Punjabi.
But I write in Punjabi.
I sing Punjabi songs.
I think every
regional language has
a texture which stands
out when it's introduced
in the mainstream culture.
That's why I think Punjabi is
the most acceptable language
in Indian film industry.
Like everybody
wants to be Punjabi
in Indian film industry.
It's crazy.
But I think now we've over
discovered Punjab, and Dehli,
and moving towards Bengal now.
Yeah, I'm playing a Bengali
character in my next film.
So I think, yeah, as I
said, I think every language
has a great texture.
It just makes a song unique.
It's makes it sound
better, in fact, in a way.
Otherwise, it becomes
too generic, Hindi songs.
I've sung two Hindi
songs, in fact.
One is "Yahin Hoon
Main," my last number.
And the other one
is "O Heeeriye,"
which is almost Hindi.
Only the [INAUDIBLE] is Punjabi.
The rest is Hindi.
AUDIENCE: Hey Ayushmann.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Hi.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: Gujarat.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Gujarat
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
A vegetarian guy is walking.
His spirit is so vegetarian.
AUDIENCE: That is true.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: You know,
my soul is very vegetarian,
but I'm a non-vegetarian.
AUDIENCE: So OK, you are
vegetarian still, right?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Huh?
AUDIENCE: You eat vegetarian.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I love vegetarian.
AUDIENCE: When you
ask him where he
is, he normally
replies depending
on the girl and friend.
[INAUDIBLE] depends on the
girl and the friend, usually.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I didn't hear you.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, I
think-- can you just increase
the level of the sound more?
I just--
AUDIENCE: I'm saying
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
AUDIENCE: You're very smart
sometimes, you know that?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
[?
AUDIENCE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH] ?]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I have a mask, too.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
All right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I want to
ask you, so do you still
follow "Roadies."
And if so, what are
your opinions about it?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
No, I don't follow
that reality show anymore.
In fact, during my time,
"Roadies" was very different.
It was just a
journey from point A
to point B. And
used to have tasks.
There was no bitchiness.
There was no gossip.
There was no backbiting.
It was slightly different.
That's why the [INAUDIBLE]
also [INAUDIBLE].
Like "Roadies 2" was, I think,
the most boring season ever.
I think it became
interesting after that.
And you'd be surprised,
during my season,
there was one girl from National
Law School of Bangalore.
Then there was another girl
who were the London School
of Economics from "Roadies."
So we were a bunch of nerds
and gave no content at all.
I was also a nerd in college.
So I think "Roadies" is becoming
interesting now, but I hardly
get time to follow.
AUDIENCE: Right, right, OK.
So you appreciate more
the task in "Roadies."
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Of course, of course.
I think that's pure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have to say, I
have lost track of my question
for sure.
I have to say.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: OK, so
what's your answer, then?
AUDIENCE: But still, I
can think of something.
So when did you realize
to explore your acting
capabilities, like
singing and then acting?
So when did you actually
realize to go ahead for acting.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I
was in St. John's High
School in Chandigarh.
And I was the co-curricula
captain of the school.
I was interested in
music and theater.
And my first musical was "Joseph
and His Amazing Technicolor
Dreamcoat," which is an
Andrew Lloyd Webber play.
So I sang in that played
as well, performed
as one of the lead cast.
And I started young, as I said.
And I'm a very
self-conscious person.
I'm quite shy.
But my father used to
really push me to perform.
AUDIENCE: I can feel that.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH] Her
birthday party, we made
her dance with [INAUDIBLE],
because my father
used to force me.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] because
I am intrinsically a very shy
person.
So I think, to come
out of the shell,
my father really
helped me a lot.
I think your parents really
need to discover your talent
and hone in a certain way
that your intrinsic character
doesn't come in the way.
So I guess that
shell was broken,
and I became a natural
over the years.
I don't try too hard.
I just be who I am.
I it's easier to be like that.
If you're being
somebody else, then I
think you may not last forever.
And if you take
your life as it is,
if you're simple as a person,
you have minimalistic needs
to fulfill your life, I think
it's easy to be like that.
AUDIENCE: OK, can I tag
along one more question.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Yeah you
can, question number two.
AUDIENCE: So what do you enjoy
doing more, singing or acting?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I'm more
of an actor than a singer.
I'm not a trained singer.
I used to get classical
training as a kid,
but never took it too seriously.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I was
always interested in acting.
And I thought, I'll always
become an actor who sings,
not a singer who acts.
And I also think that singing
is more difficult than acting.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: But singing.
Music [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Huh.
Acting [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] So
I think singing music is more
technical than acting.
Acting is more subjective.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Its as simple as that.
AUDIENCE: I have to say, I loved
your pairing with Yami Gautam.
And I'm really looking forward
to your acting with Parineeti.
And I love your "Dum
Laga Ke Haisha" the most.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I think it's, again,
a personality trait.
I am a very laid back person.
I'm not hyper ambitious.
I like living my life.
I like discovering new
places, new people.
And apart from that,
it's always good to be
under-rated than over-rated.
I think, at the end of the
day, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
It's OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
it makes no sense.
So I think it's all right.
But I think I
should do, ideally,
at least two films a year.
As of now, I'm doing just a
one film, just one film a year.
So let's see.
It also depends on
the scripts and also
depends on the kind
of films that I get.
So I am slightly
picky and choosy.
I just follow my heart.
I don't follow my mind most of
the time. [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I think I just do
what I want to do.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: I think your first
movie is "Vicky Donor."
So what was your first reaction
when you heard the story and--
[LAUGHTER]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: I
think the first reaction
was, I know this, how to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Second reaction was
that-- there was
a task in "Roadies."
it was a sperm donation
task in "Roadies."
Serious, true story.
When I was 20 in Allahabad,
I donated sperms, for real.
Out of five contestants,
three samples were selected.
I was one of those.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
So technically, I'm
a method actor.
[LAUGHTER]
So I did not cringe at all
because I knew that this
was the need of the hour.
And people are
going through that.
And when I read the
script it was quite clean.
There was nothing creepy
or cringy about it.
And Shoojit Sircar was a
National Award-winning director
already.
So I guess I trusted
the director.
And the script was so good.
And since I had done
that thing in the past,
it was just karmic, I think.
AUDIENCE: But the best part is,
you acted so well that I never
realized it's your first movie.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Thank you so much.
I could sleepwalk the character
because I am from that milieu.
I am from Delhi, Chandigarh.
So the language was easy.
The thing was also quite OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So are we going
to your "Vicky Donor"
type of movies more
in some time future,
like that's one of the
best movies I've ever seen.
Like [INAUDIBLE].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: First of
all, nice testicle-- sorry
spectacles.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I think, if the sequel
in the making, definitely
I'll go for it.
But otherwise, I
think it's always
good to go for quirky subjects
which are slightly edgy.
And I'm sure the audiences
are prepared for it.
And we live in a
day and age when
people are experimenting a lot.
Either there's a
superstar, or super script.
Till the time I don't
become a superstar,
I'll go the super script.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Ayushmann.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Hi, how are you.
AUDIENCE: So, for
stuff like [INAUDIBLE],
for the last movie, like
"Dum Laga Ke Haisha,"
you were awesome in that movie.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my question is that
you played a character of '90s
in that movie.
And you've grown up by
listening some of Kumar Sanu.
So how was your experience like
performing a dance of a Kumar
Sanu sung song?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I love Kumar Sanu.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, same.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
I just feel I should dance.
We are '90s kids
and nostalgia holds
a lot of value in my life.
We live in the past.
We think about those--
I think every song,
you have a memory attached
to it, to every song.
And I think it was quite an
eager subject, "Dum Laga Ke
Haisha," fat wife, this husband,
intelligent, illiterate.
So I think there's a clash
of personalities in the film.
Both want [INAUDIBLE].
And when I read the
script for the first time,
and I was blown away.
And I guess it worked.
I'm glad it worked.
It was not a big budget film,
just like "Vicky Donor,"
and did pretty well.
So you I hope I continue to
make such choices in life.
AUDIENCE: So I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm from Delhi.
So I just want to ask
you, being an outsider,
how difficult was it for you
to make a mark in the Bollywood
industry in the beginning?
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I think the industry
has become more open now.
It has become more
accepting now.
I'm not the only one.
There are other actors
also, like [INAUDIBLE]
who are not from the
industry and doing well.
And I'm glad I'm
born in this era.
I read this book
called "Outliers."
It says that, if
you're fortunate,
you have to choose
the right era.
And if I was an aspiring
actor in the early 2000s,
or '90s, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I'm glad I became
an actor in 2012.
It was the correct era.
And it just worked.
And I think this is the
time when, every year, there
will be debutantes making
their way from television,
other mediums, modeling,
or maybe, people
who are from outside
the industry.
So I think it's a great time--
not just for the actors,
also for the directors,
scriptwriters, producers.
There are new
producers coming up.
So I think it's an open world
now, in Bollywood especially.
It was infested with
nepotism earlier.
But now it's become more open.
AUDIENCE: Just
one more question,
which one is your favorite?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
or "Vicky Donor."
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
I think "Vicky Donor"
made me a household name.
The character had
a lot of spunk.
"Dum Laga Ke Haisha"
was despicable
in the first half the,
character of Prem,
and became positive
in the second half.
But I think I've worked
really hard for "Dum Laga Ke
Haisha," because the language
was not naturally coming out
for me.
I'm a Punjabi.
"Vicky Donor" was
just a sleepwalk.
"Dum Laga Ke Haisha,"
I really worked
on the language,
the body language
because Prem is not me.
I was playing somebody
else in the film.
AUDIENCE: Ayushmann, your latest
movie, "Meri Pyaari Bindu"--
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA: This film
is about a Bengali writer who is
in love with his
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So it's about that.
He just loves that
person in the film.
AUDIENCE: Well yeah,
good luck, man.
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
Love thy neighbor.
It's about that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So when Ayushmann said
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[APPLAUSE]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AYUSHMANN KHURRANA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
Thank you so much.
Yeah yeah, so we ended
with a song, all right?
[SINGING] Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]